CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is with us she was
homeland security and counterterrorism
adviser to President George W Bush Fran
good morning you've seen the president
make his remarks yesterday what do you
think he believes about Russian
interference in the election and current
Russian interference so I mean look he
has he always makes these qualifying
statements he does there's two things I
think about it John one I think he
conflates collusion with meddling and
the effect on the election these are
three separate things the intelligence
community has been quite clear with him
and dan coates as recently as this week
after the his fumble in Helsinki made
clear it's a fact the Russians
interfered in the 2016 election and they
continue meddling in to this day they
the intelligence community made no
assessment of the effect of that
meddling on the 2016 results and no one
and Bob Muller has a mind yet about
collusion and so these are separate
things the president seems to conflate
and let's take those two things apart
let's leave the past in the past Dan
Coates said in February America is under
attack from the Russians he then last
week said a version of the same thing
from the Russians and then after they
all think he said it a third time this
is about what's happening today and the
president told you a floor well I have
to look isn't it strange if you're
director of intelligence says we are
under attack that a president would say
well I'd have to look at that sure he
already have that pretty much top of
mind every morning right well one would
think that he's already looked at it
right and he's been briefed about it in
excruciating detail dan coates and the
intelligence folks are in there for like
two hours a day talking to him so I'm
quite sure that he's been briefed about
it you know it's hard to understand why
he always hedges here you know it's very
clear it was the Russians who meddled in
the 2016 election not others it's true
others do hack into the United States
but not in the election what the
intelligence community says said is it's
the Russians and the president seems
constitutionally incapable of just
stating the fact well you've worked in
the White House and we were going to
would and wouldn't ' and all of that
wouldn't someone in the White House if
that if he had just misspoke what
shouldn't someone have said immediately
let's correct this right away instead of
waiting 26 hours to do so that's right
I mean I was in a white house and you
often have to correct a statement you
know normally the staff gets sent out
it's the old Washington thing John knows
what the president meant to say was his
press secretary was with him if there
was a mere misstatement of wood wouldn't
Sarah Huckabee Sanders would have done
it then and there or he would have had
him do it in his first interview so it's
just not credible and by the way if he
really wanted to correct his and and
help his relationship fix his
relationship with his intelligence
community you would have fixed it on
foreign soil where you insulted them not
waited 26 hours back in the white what
is this do for morale at the
intelligence community's within them
Mike Morell was on yesterday saying if
there were up to him he would advise
some of these Chiefs to consider
stepping down well I think I think we
should assume they did I mean I we have
to ask ourselves what would have caused
the president who's not prone to
correcting himself publicly to go out 26
hours later and I think you've got to
assume there was some pretty tough talk
inside the White House in advance of
that correction by intelligence Chiefs
who may very well have threatened to
resign no that was fascinating Fran
Townsend thanks so much